the author of reborn in the usa an
englishman's love letter to his chosen
home available now wherever you get your
books
and one of the men in men in blazers
joining us
mere moments after england bounces
germany in front of the home
fans in the famous uh
wembley at lunt in london is none other
than roger bennett i can't believe i get
the opportunity to chat with you first
blush after england
advances to the quarterfinals in the
euro cup sir
holy holy holy crap rich
all it took for england to win a big boy
game in a tournament
against the germans was for me to
release a book about my love of the
united states of america
the timing is is uh is unique let's just
put it that way but
you must be out of your skull right now
roger well i won't be completely clear
to you rich eisen to your audience
my accent does scream liverpool my
heart is you know team america i have
become american
i ride with america when america play
england as they did in the women's world
cup where alex morgan city
and told piers morgan exactly where he
could put it
you know i root for the americans all
day and all night
but i will say said that as a child of
liverpool
to watch france crap the bed yesterday
in the euros and then the germans today
i'll just say that doesn't get old which
isn't the first time in my life
england have beaten germany in
tournament play they've been ralph
wiggum
perpetually since 1966 um
against germany every single time just
oh
just the germans just know how to do it
this was
this was a day in which english dreams
will now be
turned up to 11. and i know again your
your book is about being reborn in the
usa
and yeah and and and what your book is
about
that said what what what is it going to
be like on the streets of london
tonight right now roger um the whole not
just
london picture the whole nation of
england
will just be like one giant city
of philadelphia they better
reach those telephone poles is all i am
telling you we are
the whole of england and i often split
with my pronouns when i say way i mean
they
yes it will be it will be philadelphia
eagles winning the super bowl and this
was just this was just a round of 16
game
there is no doubt in my mind we will
know probably go and crap the bed in the
next
game against weaving or whatever but
honestly
for england to beat germany i want to be
clear the only thing they can do better
than beating the germans this is
i mean the germany are just they they
are the death star
for us they are just so unbelievably
powerful we essentially today i don't
like to be hyperbolic but we saw luke
skywalker take a
furry proton torpedo down uh down an air
duct that's how much of a remarkable
spectacle it was for me to witness today
it was genuinely incredible
and it doesn't matter yes they may now
go on that we can talk about how deep
but this day for england ballads will be
written about this day
tapestries will be woven fathers sons
mothers daughters will pass on this
story for generations
well and and the last 48 hours in this
tournament have been
just stupendous roger uh the the matches
of uh monday with
both uh spain and france uh
blowing two goal leads and ultimately
the french as you put it crapping the
bed
um and that's how you say it in french
rich
uh mayor melding uh the uh
i don't know i don't know how to say bad
i used to i took french in high school
my wife's fluent in it
i'm less than less than basically that's
what i'm saying
feels like the golden state warriors
giving up a 3-1 lead is genuinely
you know first of all this tournament is
it's remarkable it's happening at all
remember this is cancelled last summer
as the whole
continent was under the grip of the
pandemic so to see
just the cities across europe many with
with fans packing the stadium again
for me it's remarkable
national team jerseys they're singing
their national anthems and this
tournament does feel special for them
you can see there's almost a joy as they
take the field the jury of kids the
naive joy of being together they are not
taking him for granted
either and the football these guys are
exhausted they're shattered they play
pandemic
seasons they are utterly mentally
exhausted physically exhausted
and they are just going for it it's a
tournament in which no lead is safe you
know we've all emerged from lockdown
uh i will say however much we are going
for it in life
no one has emerged from lockdown drunker
than euro 2020
roger bennett here on the rich eisen
show he also uh
could not uh help but notice the
ruthian shot call uh from the men in
blazers twitter account
during the penalty kicks yesterday
mbappe missed coming
and then sure enough wow
that was that was you i imagine correct
not davies who tweeted that one
that was me that was me that was that
was a that was a
now you know people don't turn to us for
footballing knowledge rich
that is a shocking moment people don't
think that we
know what we're talking about we like
people to think that we don't know what
we're talking about
but bappe is a is a young giant of the
game the penalty shootout
americans may i mean it's like russian
roulette it's really a game
a game that is only loosely connected to
everything that comes before it
football's a
the ultimate team game and they yeah
they've run out of time you're like lads
let's have a one-on-one thing they
should really just have a dance-off they
really should
a dance-off between the team's best
dancers
would be as connected to the game as
football as the crucible of the penalty
shootout so this is one of the best
players in the world going to the pelham
12 year you're so close you cannot you
could touch almost the goalkeeper
but it's just a psychological test of
nerve and
umbape who had misfired the whole
tournament you could see you were second
guessing um
i mean he's he's gone from a world
beater essentially in his
shooting action to shaquille o'neal at
the free throw line
and it wasn't a surprise it was not a
surprise and it was very dark when a
player misses and his nation crumples
because of his action it's a lot for one
human being especially one so young
but that can he miss we will predict he
will come back please god stronger
more determined more tenacious for that
experience and will dominate
for for years to come would you prefer
to go first or last in a in a pk
roger what's the benefit um if you mean
if i was if united states during the
world cup finals yes and uh we're in the
huddle
and the manager says roger what are you
feeling
um i think you know i
it really doesn't matter to me to be
candid i'd do whatever our nation needed
i do it with soiled underpants that's
for sure
um and i would deliver glory i would i
would it would be i've built for this
it's one of the sad parts of my life i
dreamt of
representing the nation i still maintain
that dream you know my book
yep um i write about meeting the chicago
bears the super bowl winning team
i met them at o'hara or four a.m in the
morning walter payton my hero
uh jim mcmahon everybody you know a
nation's darling the punky qb
and of course william refrigerator perry
um
who was just a carnival of joy i had his
poster above my bed in liverpool
and at 4am in the morning he put his big
arm around me
i was 50 i was like i dreamt of america
i'd lived through the bears their their
glory had shown me it was
you could throw off 20 years of
failure and self sabotage and become a
winner which i personally you know i
needed that my own
personal narrative and william perry put
his arm around me and he whispered into
my ear
he said dream big dreams you can do
anything
if i can do it you can too which you
know now i know
now i work in sports i know it's just um
what every uh
athlete says to any kid just every
cliche that they whisper to every kid
but
when i was 15 i was like william perry
is telling me to move
to america and um and so yeah i do dream
of taking that penalty kick and when the
nation needs me i am there
yes but would you prefer to go first or
last russia
for america's choice uh america i would
probably
uh i think i'd do a job last that's the
most nerve-wracking one they need the
gentleman that brings tenacious
tenacity and also rich you know me i'm
dead inside i have no feelings
so i would not be i would not be on the
ground
honestly roger that's one of the many
reasons why i love you is you fully
admit that and plus you and i being part
of the bald brotherhood you're giving me
a bilf life mug that i have here in
studio
um just seeing just seeing you know that
the german
the german manager's hair it just it
just it's impressive
uh just seeing the the perfectly cut
suits
uh from some of these managers as well i
mean southgate's
look is just amazing and and then
there's never a crease out of order it's
just as a
i'm i'm stunned by it i'm really just
taken aback by the fashion
and the pageantry as well the fashion
the anthems the pageantry the own girls
you
are you were bald before trey young made
it cool
you're a pioneer you are an og of
baldness now all the kids are doing it
it's true
but roger trey so are you saying tr
trey's gonna be one of us soon is it
what you're saying
why are you why are you future tenting
it how are you future tempting
he's there young pound per pound is
probably i would say the best bald
athlete in the world
i think i i watch him it's one of the
many things i don't understand like i
know
i know so many red-headed human beings
who like watch kevin hurt her and just
feel so close to him red velvet he
represents all of us
it's one of the things that annoys me
about people i love how we're talking
about everything apart from my book here
rich yeah it's okay
it does it does annoy me you've got me
off you've got me angry i'm like it's a
jag like everybody connects to
their symbol of representation we balls
we don't support each other we don't
look at each other and nod we don't feel
pride in each other's accomplishments
and i do what i say i do i look at trey
young as a bald man
i look at him and i'm like trey young
you are a king bald you represent all of
us and it's
genuinely thrilling to see the fact that
we are talking about other aspects other
than your book though roger
shows how your book is i in my mind it
just shows you that your book is going
to touch upon so many other different
things because you're a rack on tour and
you're an expert on so many different
things like this
that you could call your shot that trae
young is already in the bald brotherhood
uh it's i i find i think i think it's
just like a full circle
quite frankly he's a leader
and again i do i do you know in all the
sports there's no one i watch
and savor more than that man right now
can we talk about my book
yes raj it's independence day it's july
4th it's america's i love it it's just a
time of glory and i want to spread the
love
about america it's a time to genuinely
not to everything here that we often
take for granted after a couple of years
of
chaos and challenge oh that's why i
wrote it
so did i did i pick up what what what
you mentioned earlier before that that
william the refrigerator perry
was part of your um your your early on
process about
falling in love with this country and
wanting to move here
or that just absolutely no kidding
absolutely 100 william refrigerated
perry not him alone i mean
um really it started with jonathan and
jennifer hart
the movies of john hughes miami vice
when you see crockett and tubbs
you know that that was that was i i was
a flailing gentleman
full of self-loathing and no
self-confidence and really miami vice
yes it might have been
a show about two guys keeping the world
safe from
uh from the evil intent of drug cartels
but really it was
as i say animal farm is a book about
horses and pigs it was really a
manual of self-confidence aimed at teams
around the globe be singular in style
find a look stick to it even when you're
going on a drug bust don't wear kevlar
just wear periwinkle t-shirt with your
sleeves rolled up no socks and a spad
reel
just always be yourself and um so i
everything i watched the chicago bears i
guess i talked about them earlier
to to throw off your narrative of 20
years of
a failure of wasting the career of the
greatest man
walter payne to ever pull in your jersey
right and suddenly become a all
buccaneering or fighting swaggering
you know trash-mouthing boosting team
who backed up those boats with glory
against
arguably new england patriots greatest
ever quarterback in my book
tony easton and i i i've watched each of
these and just talk from them lessons
about how to be in the world and i grew
up in liverpool the greatest city in the
world but
liverpool was really falling apart in
the 1980s
the north of england was economically
devastated politically
disempowered the steel mills in the
north the coal
the cotton closed down and england
liverpool had no reason to be my life
has lived in black and white you know it
was high unemployment there was massive
heroin epidemic
and i survived this kind of time of
darkness by making believe
i was an american who was trapped in an
englishman's body
by listening to tracy chapman listening
to run dmc
watching the bears and really i
persuaded myself i was american before
i'd ever set foot in this country
and the book is really about how
externally the idea of america
can fill you with courage with belief
with aspiration
with a sense that a different
possibility to the one that you're
currently experiencing is there
and that's something i've made real by
moving here becoming american and thank
god as you know rich they like
all men on television so it's all gone
okay
and is that a photograph of you skate
roller skating on the uh on the front uh
or is that a skateboard of you on the
the front cover
of the box it is it's a 16 year old
roger about to go to the beastie boys
concert
in liverpool which ended within one song
as the beastie boys were canned off by
my fellow liverpudlians and a rioting
huge which was tear gas by the police
and as rock was arrested another moment
when i realized
if i wanted to do something to be
something to save her something i had to
leave
and then of course tracy chapman's album
took over the world and
um just listening to her lyrics about
make bold moves
uh if you are miserable don't just
wallow in your misery get out while you
still
can that kind of that kind of completed
the narrative and i moved to chicago
really at the earliest opportunity and i
i just and what i will say
so this has been a timer challenge for
america the past couple of years
we're just emerging from lockdown a time
of chaos a time of darkness
um i i have stood in a in a courtroom
in lower manhattan we have 162 american
new americans who came from 41 countries
all around the world many of whom
struggled to be here you know escaped
civil wars
famines worse um and we were all united
by
the dream of america by the idea of
america and to be in that room to save
the oath to become american to fulfill
a dream when you've done that you can it
gives you such a sense of america as a
place that can give courage that can
give joy that can give deep deep meaning
and that's really what i wanted to
convey with my american story in this
book
and again it's reborn in the usa an
englishman's love letter to his chosen
home available now where all books are
sold just in time for july
the 4th uh congrats on that roger i
appreciate the time i always appreciate
your
your wit your sensibility and our
conversations i really appreciate it
ricardo eisen you are doing the lord's
work and mate
it's coming home i appreciate it
so uh i guess before i let you go one
last uh uh uh
football question then um is it this
tournament
who's the favorite now could it be
england i mean spain
uh i mean germany and france are now out
who's your favorite here i'm portugal
this portugal right there's a tournament
that
i think the scriptwriter must be
christopher nolan it is it is so
batty it is so insane and narrated only
a fool would make a prediction so i will
make a prediction if that's the case
and i think not england that's who will
win it i love it
to your listeners to your viewers ahead
of uh july 4th wish you all love and
courage
for having me you bet reborn in the usa
in english and his love letter
is chosen home the author roger bennett
right here on the rich eyes and shove a
great fourth raj
thanks guys the best raw the best at raj
bennett on twitter at men and blazers on
twitter and instagram as well
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here